hey guys welcome to the room and report
i'm dave rubin we are doing a one-on-one
this week we have a guy who needs no
introduction and truly a living legend
how about that intro dead legend better
than a dead legend Larry King welcome to
the reuben report thank you David great
to be with you always have loved having
you on my show and scraped to return the
compliment I appreciate that actually
the first time i was on your show I had
a sweating fit when we did that
Republican National Convention and you
told that you told me I was sweating
more than Albert Brooks in broadcast
news which is truly one of the greatest
moments of my career broadcast news is
one of the all-time great movies I think
great great movie about the media well
for everything we do right and for me
especially because I saw that movie two
weeks after quintuple bypass surgery Wow
and i sat next to Mike Wallace
everyone's at Diane so the whole the
whole in crowd in New York and my
surgery was in New York so we all
attended that filming everybody loved
yeah alright well you know let's start
with a little bit about the media so you
have been around the media for basically
your whole life and at least 57 years 57
years but who's counting what what do
you think are the biggest changes in the
way the media landscape has you know
you're you're doing an online show now
we're doing it on making changes one
technical in that when I started there
was a radio and television and landlines
and telephone lines and then came
satellites and now we have internet and
all the technological end has been
incredible and that has led to 500
channels and anything goes and you know
when Jackie Gleason went off the air he
had 33 million viewers there was no show
that that approaches 20 million viewers
so the pie is cut up in many many slices
and we all have a little piece of a
slice piece of pie rather sore and I
left CNN I thought I could retire and
then Along Came Carlos Slim on the
internet now I'm on the internet every
day and who knows who knows what's next
the delivery system now the basic hasn't
changed this one-on-one
has not changed we still need the human
being it has that hasn't changed the
method of delivery has changed are we
losing something with the one on one I
mean really what your trademark is this
what we're doing right now we don't get
that in a way that we used to sadly
enough because it's a it's been eight it
up spitting out go to next thing you
know cause there's up and grab something
jump on it stay bang it out then go
whatever it was next and a lot of it
leads to I mean some of it is absurd
addy hmm i miss in-depth interviews you
don't see much of that anymore on on
cable television you know it's going
away everywhere and i said do you think
it's just a function of technology or is
there actually something else going is
there something about humans and the way
we're evolving now maybe it's about
humans or about management or about the
people running networks now or we call
them the suits they didn't come up the
broadcast their accountants their appeal
the pushes you know they work with what
this works that does or keep business
doesn't work you know classic example
was it mild network CNN wishes I loved
every day of my twenty five and a half
years there I did a lot for them they
did a lot for me it was a great career
Ted Turner was the best person I've
award for but I didn't speak to speak
with Ted recently but if he saw what was
going on now for example the airplane
yeah let's go to another for example
they covered that 24 hours a day they
missed in you had the Russians going
into Ukraine the other day in one day i
watch the show and say i forget the show
but they never mentioned other news it
was airplane oh yeah and the airplane
was all conjecture we think it landed
here we might have gone here with you
since day two they made that advance
nothing in that story but conjecture it
was breaking supposition breaking
speculation it was never breaking news
so if you were there now I don't know
what you dealt with it but hey oh I'd
have insisted let's do other things how
they would have said we got a tremendous
audience then well they're the network i
would have gone
we there's nothing I could do is to
break it I would have tried to urge for
example the other day while CNN and some
other cable news networks I'm sure we're
doing airplane coast-to-coast
wire-to-wire 10 people in Washington yep
were killed in a mudslide there were
three Americans on that plane ten
Americans died in a mudslide in
Washington no coverage the g8 conference
in Russia was canceled rescheduled for
Belgium with Russia left out no mention
an enormous enormous occurrence in
Houston of an oil slick that destroyed
hundreds and hundreds of miles of water
not covered the President of the United
States is in the Netherlands he's
talking to China about trying to get
China to at least stay neutral in the
Russian situation no coverage yes now
that is abysmal so who do we blame for
this because I i I'm with you everybody
knows this but is it is it a matter of
ratings vs ladies vs logic yeah so why
does all right but the and the reason
that that doesn't work is alright you
get super ratings and you think
advertisers don't know that these
ratings are based on a hyped-up thing
okay so what happens after the incident
is over whenever it ends and you got to
decide when does it end when is the
public lose interest then you go back to
your other program you sink down again
the advertisers ain't gonna buy it for
the next six months based on that too we
jump because the only what it was like
buying I'm gonna by CBS I'm gonna buy
NBC for a year because boy the Super
Bowl did great Super Bowl the great I
better by NBC next Tuesday no no there's
none other with the other but that's
let's think and it's it's sad to be